hey youtubers it's Charlie so community
is finally back season 5 premiered with
a double episode and even though we kind
of knew a lot of things going into the
new season I was still surprised by a
few the plot points this video will
cover both of those episodes so let's do
our top 5 moments and then I'll do my
best Nicolas Cage impression no no that
would be terrible that would totally
showed my voice so but I will do review
though so here we go number 5 Dan
Harmon's meta-narrative this actually
wasn't a plot point but it's his crazy
subtext that makes the show so awesome
think about the zach braff book ends at
the beginning they have this offhand
joke about repotting and scrubs season 9
so they're talking about how they're
going to bring the study group back
together and how in real life they're
going to keep community season 5 fresh
they're also making fun of donald glover
leaving the show after the first couple
of episodes because he actually is doing
that just like zach braff did on scrubs
then at the end of the episode they have
this actual voiceover from Zach Braff
like he used to do on scrubs it's new
they actually had Zach Braff come in and
record new dialogue for it that kind of
thing is just crazy awesome and we would
never see it if Dan Harmon weren't
running the show again so I'm really
grateful that he's back number four the
world of Greendale teachers Jeff
becoming a teacher was actually
surprising to me but the thing that I
love most about it is that it'll allow
us to see this micro universe of
Greendale teachers we kind of got to see
how ridiculous it is but I think most of
the future plots will just revolve
around that teachers as characters in a
much bigger way to be honest I'm not
super invested in Jeff learning to be a
better person this year I actually have
the feeling that by the end of the
season he'll be right back where he
started having to choose between winning
and being a good person his character
would not be good if he got these happy
endings
that's kind of why I really didn't like
season Ford's because all the characters
got to graduate and I feel like
Greendale should not allow anyone to
leave like that's why it's supposed to
be so awful but there's this whole joke
about how Greendale sucks the life out
of people so you know no one should get
a totally happy ending on community
number three the new Chang last season
Chang became this weird plot device and
it was all about is he lying and why is
he lying
I loved how in a few seconds he gave
that math teacher speech and they just
brush past all of that stuff it totally
made him funny again and I loved how
later in the episode you just didn't see
the house arrest
bracelet they just dropped this
storyline one of the things I really
like about Chang this season so far is
that he's like this disgusting fairy
that they used to speed up the story
when it looks like it's getting too slow
like whenever a knee joint Jeff's class
you know he just kind of jumped in in
the background with that quick joke I
have a feeling he's going to be doing
that a lot this season number two the
Nicolas Cage class and Abed I just love
the idea of Nicolas Cage as a topic they
could explore at Greendale
the guest star teachers performance and
Abed's impersonation were a little too
on the nose
but Abed string plot his big plan all
around that room was hilarious it was
like a Dreamatorium level moment I'm
really bummed that Donald Glover is
leaving after the first couple of
episodes because I think it means that
we're not going to see the Dreamatorium
again but that remains to be seen we
still might end up seeing it sometime
this season and my number one moment
Jonathan banks if he didn't catch it him
sitting down at the study table means
that he is in a small way at least
occupying the space in the narrative
that Pierce would normally have to be
clear he's not the new Pierce but he is
the old guy and he is very funny in this
Breaking Bad I might slit your throat
kind of way I love the way the story
this year brings him into the study
group you know via this save Greendale
plot that's probably going to cover most
of the season Jonathan banks is almost
in every single episode it's gonna be
amazing
watching him be this really twisted
obi-wan Kenobi to Jeff this season in
all honesty though it was that first
moment with Jeff the meatballs and
Leonard that really sold me on his
character let me know what your favorite
moment was in the comments below you
know wasn't the joke density level
rising to season three levels was it
Jonathan banks was it all the Nicolas
Cage stuff there are so many things to
like about these first two episodes
overall I love the episode I'm totally
sold on the save Greendale plot I love
the fact that Jonathan banks is on the
show now and he fits in the narrative I
totally love how he exploded the idea of
minuses and pluses I'm gonna have to
completely rethink all of my
relationships with my college professors
Jeff speech really did a good job of
kind of laying the groundwork for some
of the crazier storylines are gonna have
this season there's gonna be this epic
70s disaster movie episode like the Mad
Max episode that I talked about during
my preview it's all about how Greendale
is awful and they're there because
they're lame so it kind of explains why
they're so awful to each other and these
crazy situations they get themselves
into so I really love that he gave that
speech because it kind of told you how
awful and crazy things are gonna get
this season and I'm really excited for
that
it's gonna be the best possible kind of
crazy if there's anything I would give
an A - it would be Dan Harmon's you know
Ari piloting of this new season kind of
turning the show into this really funny
really meta thing again
although Jonathan banks was definitely a
high mark I'd give him a B+ we'll give
him a Plus everybody else just gets a
regular B so I'll be doing community
videos for every episode this season be
sure to subscribe to get them right now
you can actually click here to learn
more about what's going on this season
and can click here to get my Q&A video
for episode 1 at Sherlock careful for
spoilers and nets thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives